un lieu historique rideau hall la
résidence officielle des gouverneurs
généraux depuis 150 ans ici les
visiteurs affluent quotidiennement des
groupes d'étrangers visitent votre
maison explique cette professeur
d'histoire spécialiste de la royauté le
rôle semble incompatible avec la
personnalité de julie payette et en fait
lors de sa nomination il ya trois ans
julie payette a demandé qu ont effectué
des rénovations pour rendre sa résidence
plus intimes notamment avec une nouvelle
porte pour ses chats mais sa demande a
évolué elle voulait pouvoir entrer et
sortir sans que personne ne la voit
indiqué une source à la sib ici cette
source a participé à la conception d'un
escalier qui aurait donné accès à la
résidence à l'abri du regard des
visiteurs à elle seule sa conception a
coûté près de 140 mille dollars
mais aucun escaliers n'a encore été
construit
c'est qu'après avoir été informé des
coûts le bureau de julie payette dit
avoir mis les travaux sur la glace il a
été décidé d'entreprendre une analyse
plus approfondie afin de trouver un
équilibre entre la sécurité et les coûts
lors de travaux futurs
ce n'est pas tout plus de cent dix sept
mille dollars ont été dépensés pour
installer un système de sécurité autour
de son bureau afin de limiter au maximum
le nombre de visiteurs selon des sources
de la bbc julie payette n'aime pas avoir
les travailleurs qui s'occupe de
l'entretien de rideau world en son champ
de vision lui ces dépenses comme pour
s'isoler et c'est probablement excessif
c'est à dire de visage et une entrée
particulière c'est une nouvelle tuile
pour julie payette dont le mandat était
entachée par son style de gestion
le bureau du conseil privé en quête
d'ailleurs sur des allégations selon
lesquelles elle aurait créé un
environnement toxique et une culture de
la peur à rideau hall
il suffit de vincent foisy radio canada